Vision Pro in the pool now I don't
recommend this because this is not
waterproof but I thought I would give it
a try I was able to shove this bottom
part of the battery pack into my solar
Loop band and I tightened it and voila
it worked I also tucked the cables into
my bathing suit strap so that those
wouldn't get wet and I can't even look
at myself like I can't even take this
video seriously oh my gosh I'm losing it
but look at this all of my windows are
up here checking the news checking the
stocks and hey let's watch my own
YouTube video the thing that I've been
so impressed with Vision Pro is how
spatial Computing really is changing the
game like I'm walking up towards this
window it's getting closer and
everything stays right where I placed it
even the battery pack on my head